Yo, bro, are you ready to go to the happiest place on earth,
guys?
I heard that shit is fucking fire, bro.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
I don't know if I'm too big on screen.
You guys think I'm too big, or is it just okay?
I don't want to, like, I don't know.
I don't know.
I haven't, like, used, like, you know, used this skin suit
yet for gameplay.
So I don't know, like, what is the perfect size?
to be on the screen.
It's perfect.
I'm always worried if it's like too big or not because like,
you know, oh yeah, watch this.
So if I ever have to go pee,
it just works.
I'm not, guys, I'm not peeing in my sleep, guys.
It's just, you guys, it's just, my soul is peeing right now.
just so you guys know, just so you guys, there's no trauma
associated where I have to, Wet the bed or some shit.
Yeah, my soul is peeing you.
Whenever I have to use the bathroom, I can just do this.
There you go.
Yeah, I don't know.
Is this right size or should I be smaller?
I always worry that like, because like, I feel like it does
take up a lot of the screen.
So I'm like, am I too big?
Am I?
Maybe I'll make it a little bit smaller.
Maybe.
Immersion.
Fuck your immersion right now.
Trying to figure it out.
Yeah, alright, here we go.
There we go.
This is more important right now because I always get like
really...
I always get like really anal about this type of shit.
Because I want you guys to have like a...
I want you guys to be able to see what the fuck is going on
too, you know?
Can all women astral project while peeing or is just the
case?
Canadians, put your ass through.
Thank you for your super chat.
Thank you.
Of course we can.
When you guys know when we're like, we gotta go to the
bathroom and we bring like a couple of ladies with us.
We're not actually going to the bathroom.
We're here talking about you.
Yeah.
That's right.
We're here.
We're here to talking about you in the bathroom.
Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're as perfect as the day I thinking oh yeah some people
were like thinking i saw that all this time yes it's called
toilet gossip yes it's a very big thing for ladies we all go
to the toilet to gossip about people and then i guess like
touch up on makeup and stuff and then one girl will go pee
and then uh one girl will go pee the others are just there
for bathroom gossip that's right i'm revealing the women's
secrets i want to let you guys know i do not want to
disappear um i i love my life and um i am perfectly sane
right now and i do not want to disappear and i'm not going
to any isolated place by myself so if you find me my body
then someone was in she talked too much if i disappear
wanted to disappear just so just in case they get it get me
they got her you know in case someone got me i'm revealing
the women's secrets they're gonna send someone over um i
would i want to talk oh my gosh the last couple of days i'm
like all over the place right now because like i said like
you know the new year stuff um working on the new year stuff
and like i gave like a huge list of things needed to be done
yesterday uh to the project team for the new year stuff and
i'm like i've been like working non-stop the last two days
so that's why i'm like all over the place so i'm sorry when
i said fuck your immersion i really didn't mean it i'm just
wild right now
we're all here about immersion guys um anyway um anyway what
else oh yeah i was like literally last two days it's like i
wake up really i think i think i was like uh i think i was
like re what's the word um i was like uh recouping from my
sleep debt i had a lot of sleep debt um for the last week
and all i did on the sunday on sunday i just slept until 4 p
.m i i woke up just to walk dad and feed him because you
know he's gonna be like bitch walk me and i'm like and then
and then i walk him give him food and then and i i fall back
asleep and i woke up at like 4 p.m worked the whole night on
behind the scenes stuff and then went back to sleep and then
it was just repeat for monday to woke up grab something uh
grab grab something to eat for myself and then also fed dad
and then walked him went back to that my bed and then slept
till 4 p.m and then slept till 4 p.m and then worked and now
we're here now i'm still the crazy part is that i still have
five plus months of dms to to comb through like i am so
behind.
I think I've like chiseled through like maybe 20% I chiseled
through 20% of those DMs and I'm like oh because I have like
projects too like the projects are are on a separate side of
the DMs.
The DMs are something different.
The projects aren't on their own aisle that I've tackled but
don't worry the projects are fine.
It's just the other stuff.
The other stuff the Yeah, also, it's really funny.
Everyone thought that, like, when we were voting for the
Chibi representative, guys, they're like, no, I can't, but
we'll never see them again.
We'll never see the other Chibi skin suits.
Guys, I spent way too much money to never see them again.
Like, I was like, what if I even, brother, fully completed
skin suits?
We're not, they're not going to be vaulted.
Like, the Disney vault, guys.
Do not worry.
I saw some people were, like, freaking.
like why didn't you vote we're never gonna see them again
yeah it was just a one-time thing i just give you guys like
a glimpse of what could have been and then it goes into the
disney vault
like completely just god you never never again will they
show up the most expensive bit i've ever guys can see.
I'm here.
I'm still here, guys.
I did not go into the Disney vault, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Also, a little, oh, shit.
Okay, wait, I just received it.
Oh, nice.
Uh, oh, nice.
Okay, we finally have the school background.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
We actually have the school background done now.
That's actually great.
We've been waiting for the back, the custom background so
fucking long because the artists had like um there's like
personal stuff going on uh with the artists so like because
of that which i understand you know like i i for these i
don't like put a background to it so i let them go through
like their personalish like whatever personal uh life stuff
that they're going through but yeah it's finally done i
think it looks pretty cool it looks pretty cute well i'll
show you guys it let me grab the let me there was like a lot
of edits i had through with them for it um i'll show you it
right now
or just like my media file or is it next week i'm gonna take
three to four days off i'm so tired i've been like all over
the place oh my god i'm gonna take like three to four days
off next week you'll understand why you'll you'll understand
why when you see the things that i've been cooking because
like every It's December was my hell month.
It really was.
December was was too much.
Too many things going on in December.
Look.
I think it's really cute.
We finally have our school background.
Yeah.
Look at that.
There's Professor Crokey too.
Professor Crokey.
All the dragons just chilling.
Yeah.
Isn't it cute?
I just got.
get it animated and we should be good to go i can still use
the non-animated version yeah teaching us very important
lessons like boobs i guess very very important history
lesson
i don't think it's really cute they all came out looking
great
and you guys can oh there is something that they forgot
because uh oh there is here see There's the sloppy sisters.
There's Lamo.
There's the whips.
There's Snuffy over there.
There's another live.
I don't know who that.
Who the fuck is that on the corner there?
Who's that?
Who is this guy?
The corner there.
This is random non-descript dog.
Like...
This random...
I don't know who the fuck this random dog.
Who the fuck is that?
What is that?
I don't even recognize it.
Man, man.
Okay, I got to ask.
I'm like, who's this random dog in there?
Just an empty...
There's like a random dog on the side.
What else?
Oh, yeah.
I just wanted to talk about this.
But do you guys know hot showers is apparently really
dangerous for you anyway i had a nice hot shower today if
bad for you why does it feel so good like yeah i don't
remember what the what the implication was um yeah
apparently like like hot showers is actually really bad for
your body and you're supposed to like have cold showers
instead but it's like really bad for your skin or some shit
you're not supposed to burn off your fucking skin yeah yeah
they're they are un they're not dain yeah they're just
they're unhealthy which in a way is like you just slowly
like i guess like you're slowly destroying your body the
more hot showers you take or some shit yeah it's not gonna
stop me i read this information and i i will continue to
take hot showers um it strips the natural oil when you take
hot showers i'll just oil myself one day someone will invent
and it will invent something where after you take your hot
shower you spray like the you spray oil on yourself and then
bam it's the same
um but yeah also i read another article i've been reading
some very interesting articles where apparently the bigger
your butt than more there's like a sign that you might have
autism or adhd if you have a big booty
Genetic sacrifices you have to make to get that booty, you
know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's crazy.
I know, right?
Like, so if you have a big booty, maybe you should get
tested.
Just to be safe, you know?
Just to be safe.
Out with actual correlation or just a relation.
Okay, here, I'll show you.
It's from the New York Post.
from some red it's not from like uh it's not like tmz or
some it's from the new york post it's not like a buzzfeed
article like literally an actual journalist an actual so you
guys got a big booty maybe get tested just in case not
autistic but at what cost yeah you're like i have a flat no
that's why i have a dude we're like no that's why i I have a
flat ass.
No.
Look, I know you're like, look, there's, there's a, we don't
have a big benchmark when it comes to journalism, but at
least it's not TMZ.
Your backside might reveal a thing or two about your brain.
That's, a promitosh is related to having autism or age
that's, actually fucking crazy
all right um anyway let's go to disneyland i think this is a
great i think okay so originally i wasn't gonna schedule the
disneyland the disneyland stream today i was gonna do it
tomorrow but other than i was like but it'll be really funny
like in the morning we're going to a park made for children
and then at night we play nikki i thought i thought that'd
be fucking funny so that's why I played Disney yeah
Disneyland today it's like um child friendly in the morning
freaky at night you know the whiplash yeah we're here for
the we're here for the Disneyland rides I've been to actual
Disneyland a fucking long ass time though um you saw that no
I have no idea what you guys what you're talking about yeah
I saw the fucking I only saw like the article tweet.
I had it bookmarked for a while because I really wanted to
give you guys like, oh my God, guys.
Fun fact.
Gabbitt, think of a super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, I saw Lady Loki.
I'm glad that it's not on Hella because it really looked
like a Hella skin at first.
And I'm glad they actually, apparently they made a statement
being like, this is like sort of like an almost one-time
thing.
because lady loki is loki so it's technically loki um and
because people were like oh my god that means we can get
like sam wilson or something as captain america or uh or we
can get like i don't know i don't know the other marvels
like you know the all other or like i guess like miles
morale at spider-man and stuff like that and uh people were
like no like i think the devs were like someone said that
the devs were like no it's sort of like a one-time thing
because lady loki is loki it's just loki being silly you
know like loki loves transforming into like different types
of things so uh uh yeah so like it's not like not like
they're gonna do it again or some but it's cool that they
made lady loki um because she's hot as she's hot as this
fuck bro yeah more goon skins people who are complaining
about barbara's having too many gooners skins weak as hell
i'm like yeah more gooners skins let's go
yay i'm here for it yippee i am the target audience here i
I'm the problem.
Yeah, we are the real fans.
You hear the good.
Man, hot man and woman, too.
They don't discriminate on who gets the...
Okay, wait, let me...
I don't know if Sound Guy is alive.
So let me know if this is okay.
Bottom, bottom.
You guys don't see it yet because I haven't shown the video.
Here we go.
Hi, Doki.
I got my birthday merch today on my own birthday.
Can you wish me a happy birthday, please?
Of course, Delta.
Oh my gosh, why is this so small?
I mean, sorry, not you.
I'm talking about the game screen.
Happy birthday, Delta.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Delta.
Happy birthday!
I hope you have a good birthday, Delta.
I'm glad that the birthday merch arrived in time.
Let's go to Disneyland!
Disney in so long!
It's also apparently the price of going to Disney is getting
higher and higher.
I said it before, but it's cheaper to go to Japan and go to
Tokyo Disneyland than it is to fucking go to California
Disneyland or some shit or anywhere.
Any of the Disneylands in America like way too expensive now
or like especially the quality of the food you get and ah i
think disneyland food is such a scam unless you're like
american disneyland food if you're in asia for disneyland
food it's so good uh chid thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you did you know norris miff loki turned into a
mare sexed up a stallion got pregnant and give birth to
Slefner Loki's mechanically Thank you for the super chat
Thank you I actually knew that I read a lot of Norse
mythologies growing up So I actually knew that Loki was a
Was a I'll say this like With Not negatively Not derogatory
But Loki was a fucking slut
Non derogatory by the way He was a freaky freaky whore
He fucked everything just like Zeus But like actually No I
wouldn't say fuck it He gets He was like I will He was like
the first twink
It was the world's first twink
Girl Girl Oh, wait, you're right.
Alright, Union, okay.
I don't know if it's too loud or not.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Welcome to Disneyland, kids.
Welcome to Disneyland.
Wait, we gotta have...
Wait, no, HD.
We gotta have the most HD experience.
Alright, can it come down a little bit?
I don't see all the pores on this Mickey Mouse.
Okay.
Wait, speech.
Oh, yeah, by the way, this looks weird.
It'll be like, why does it look like you're on the Wii Wii?
The game was originally made for the Connect.
For the parent.
I guess, like, for parents who couldn't afford to take their
kids to Disneyland every fucking week, and they've been
begging to go.
So they just bought the Connect for their child.
Be like, you want to go to Disneyland?
You go to play this game.
It's just like this.
It's just like going to Disneyland.
I need subtitles, so I understand what the fuck Mickey is
saying.
All right, there we go.
Well, Disneyland is expensive, okay?
I understand the parents not wanting to buy, like, the
monthly pass.
I feel like monthly passes are for, like, or year passes are
for, like, adults, not for the children.
Yeah, there's literally Disneyland at home.
Okay, I need the sensitivity to be lower, please.
Yeah, it's literally, and they don't have to line up.
stand in the sun for like seven hours straight and line up
for one one amusement park ride for like um or like three
hours jesus okay please tell me there's better resolutions
okay there we go is that not what i'm at no do not discard
changes oh okay i have to lock okay guys i have to relaunch
the game give me a sec I gotta relaunch it.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
This shit is big.
Language, you're in Disneyland.
The mouse has ears everywhere.
The mouse is already listening in.
They've been listening in for years now.
Gathering my data.
It's fine.
Alright, booting up Disneyland.
Oh, the food is like crazy.
that the food is like crazy fucking expensive at american
disneylands or slash disney world um for what you can get
like what like a like a fucking hot dog is like what um oh
wait we gotta fix that there's like seven or seven or ten
dollars or some shit
oh even more i don't i just know they're like so expensive
for like a plain hot dog And then, like, I would watch,
like, these, like, Disneyland, like, park reviews of food.
And then they're, like, oh, reviewing what I, uh, showing
guys what I bought at Disneyland.
And, like, showing being, like, reviewing the food there.
And then she was like, yeah, I got this, Disneyland, the
Mickey Mouse waffles.
And they were, like, um, $15.
And they were really dry.
I'm like, Jesus, like, what for a fucking random plain
waffle with Mickey Mouse ears?
Like, oh, yeah.
And then And then like Um The Mickey Mouse You know those
infamous like Mickey mini ears Or Mickey ears They're like
what 30 plus dollars or some shit But you can get them
bedazzled and all that shit But like there are You can
People usually only wear them once And then never wear it
again
Yeah And don't get me started on pin Pin trading People
would line up for like Would like go to the park opening
Every like Tuesday or some shit to line up for line up for
exclusive pins going on sale and it will go there like 7 a
.m.
like as like to line up at the park entrance and then like
then line up at the shop itself for like one hour one to two
hours so they could buy their exclusive pins he's
my idol he's the king of capitalism Idol right there Oh gosh
It's not right It's the God from Kingdom Hearts Mickey
Yeah It was this one Alright Let's be
We'll be a girl.
Uh.
Let me choose my face.
Oh.
I'll just do her.
I'll do default.
I'll do Jane.
Oh, style.
I like her hair.
I guess I can make her blonde.
No, the brown actually is a lot better.
Which is my princess dress.
Oh yeah, and there's like the Yeah, Default What's the
female Default Jenny God, that is a red ass shirt Where the
fuck is my Disney princess dress Hello, did my mom not pay
For the full experience?
Mom!
Where's my Disney dress?
You hid me I want to be Cinderella Do you know they have
that experience Disneyland too It's called like the I don't
remember what exactly but it's like the princess slash
prince experience and it's like You can pay up to like 500
plus dollars I think it was more than that You can pay up to
500 plus dollars To get your child Dressed up in like either
a princess Or a prince outfit Because they would do like a
salon thing They would like literally like do your hair give
you like and then the um that you choose between the
different types of dresses the more fancy the dress the more
expensive it is yeah the bippity boppity boutique yeah and
they go like up to 500 plus dollars even more depending on
what dress your child decides to pick it's pretty fucked up
because you know their child's gonna pick the prettiest and
you're like sorry sweetie we're poor you explained you're
like sorry your mama can't afford this you can't Please, can
you pick the, can you please pick the $100 and under,
please?
Like, oh, it's a sound gap.
Um, it's the volume.
It's the volume, okay.
Mickey!
Oh, gosh.
I was going to get some of my friends' autographs today, but
I've been so busy with the tune election that I haven't had
the chance.
The mayor election?
Oh, my God, he's going to campaign.
He's campaigning to be the mayor.
Oh, volume is low.
Okay.
I can change the...
I'm able to change...
Oh, wait.
Can I...
Huff-buff!
Huff-dug!
Oh, wait.
I can bow, too.
Oh!
What a gentleman.
I'm having so much.
much fun make it don't let me see okay dog needs to go up
wait let me let me make him autograph oh my god wait i have
the exact same autograph book wait they still make those oh
my god that that that book is old i remember that i have the
same I got the hug from Mickey.
Look at that.
I lined up three hours for this Mickey line.
I'm going to stay here for as long as I can.
All right.
Let's see.
Uh.
All right.
Let me give Mickey some upbies in the volume.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is my options?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
No, not that one.
Oh, my God.
Where the fuck is audio?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, I can turn music down and...
Okay, I'll turn music down and then effects down and then
raise up overall volume.
Okay, let me know if it's better.
All right, we gotta go...
We gotta...
Wait.
That's it.
Move over!
I'm Mickey's number one fan.
He knows my name.
Yay!
Hi, Mickey!
No, I just want to...
I want to give you another high-five.
High-five!
Yeah!
Alright, I'll give...
That's why.
High-five again!
High-five!
Yeah!
Look, my parents paid a lot of money for me to be here.
I will high five, Mickey, for as long as I want.
Yay!
Look, apparently, like, passes are, like, what, 40?
No, I think it's, like, $60-plus now, right?
For Disney Pass?
Look, for one person, was it $50 or $60?
Yeah.
and they also have to pay for parking too her parking is
very expensive it's now above $100 for a fucking ticket holy
shit I did not know that
it's per ticket per ticket yeah okay I'm high-fiving Mickey
for as long as I can one ticket is a hundred yeah no I'm
gonna be high-fiving him the park closes yeah no wonder
people's parents bought this game instead taking their
children to disneyland what's this why is it glowing well i
need a pool hi karen the park guy know that when the matter
horn opened in 1959 it was and still let me know if the
volume is okay roller coaster and the first tubular steel
roller coaster in the world thanks for stopping by what
movie is she from guys oh green green and ghost my mom don't
wait what's this why did it glow oh main street don't he be
careful he didn't sign the terms and conditions for disney
plus did you thank you for this oh no i did oh no oh it's
okay as long as i don't die in disneyland it'll be fine
Donald Donald's my favorite by the way after I quit I kept
my employee like that's why I heard working in Disneyland is
like not great like like you literally have to apply um to
be in the what was it like the Disney University so you can
be in the so you can work at the Disney parks
this is acceptable levels of Donald I love Donald Donald's
my favorite He's my favorite Disney character.
Of course!
Yay!
Oh my god, they're gonna be so jealous.
Guys, you're gonna vote for Donald, right?
He'll be a great mayor, guys.
He'll be for the people, just like, just like Cheeby Prime.
He's my idol.
Yeah, Donald!
And he gave me a head run!
Yippee, let's dance.
Bye.
Yay.
I'm his favorite.
You could tell.
I'll have, you know what?
I gave, I want another autograph from Don.
I want two autographs.
I'm greedy.
Donald, I 100% believe Donald over Mickey.
I think him as a character, he's, because like, Mickey is
now so sanitized because he's, like, the mascot, the face of
Disney, that there are two scared of giving him a
personality now.
Yeah, high five!
Tim, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, boy!
When I become mayor, free park entry for everyone.
After a small 4.99, major convenience meet.
Hot dog!
Yeah, that's why.
Don't vote for mayor.
Don't vote for Mickey Mouse for mayor, guys.
He's lying.
He's lying to you all.
All he speaks are lies.
Yeah, high five!
High five!
Yeah!
My parents paid $100 plus dollars for this ticket.
So I will high-five Donald until his hands bleed.
The mouse only wants your money exactly.
All Donald wants is recognition.
He should have been the face of Disney.
Him!
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
New items have been locked in the shop.
Check it out.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck is this guy?
What?
That's how much magic we got.
Magic?
Magic is real?
Magic is real!
Oh my god!
Oh hey, there's...
How do I... Hello.
Hello.
How do I activate this?
I want to get my fortune told.
Hello, everyone.
Is that John Disneyland?
Is that him?
Oh my god.
It's Walt Disney's soul possessing the Kinect game.
Do you think they'll take me to the basement where they
froze, cryogenically froze Walt Disney?
Hello.
I got Donald's autograph.
Yippee!
This autograph book's not for me.
Is there Goofy?
He outsourced.
Goofy outsourced to him and he outsourced to me.
And I get paid like 10-5%.
He takes 50.
I take 5.
It's like the full outsource cycle.
See, I told you guys.
He is the king of capitalism.
He truly, Mickey truly is the king of capitalism.
He's my idol.
I'll still vote for Donald, but he's my idol.
to disney where's goofy where the fuck is goofy where does
he hang out i'll fucking know where goofy hangs out oh wait
oh there it is follow the magic he's so proud of his son
where's goofy where is he hey yuck i need it i need to tell
i need to find goofy and warn him warn him about the war oh
my god where the fuck they positioned him so far from
everyone else
oh hey goofy does no one else want to meet with goofy um
he's goofy though come on guys does no one else want to talk
to goofy he's goofy yeah Howdy, Miss.
I'm goofy.
How about you?
Oh, yeah.
Donald signed that for me.
Gorge, thanks.
Yeah!
Five!
Half five!
You know, I know the new joint face up.
I'm sorry.
Goofy, they're looking for new members in phase.
Don't want you.
It's not phase down, though.
They're gone.
Yay!
Look at you!
Yeah, look at me, dude.
I can do the same, too.
Look at me!
I can twirl!
Yippee!
What?
Can I have your autograph?
Remember how to spell my name.
Oh no, Goofy's illiterate.
It's okay, buddy.
It's okay.
You still were able to smash Goofy.
Yeah!
Oh!
He's so strong!
Oh my god, he like fucking flung me.
Goofy, no.
Good boy, pal.
Donald promise we don't know puppies yeah A good dog goofy
dog Mickey needs to see you I can tell Oh my god my voices
my voices are telling me things saying that Mickey needs me
Yeah, maybe he's just he's acting goofy Uh to get the ladies
After watching the latest defunct line came to conclusion
how Stitch was the first to do a B2 meeting Grief.
Stitch kind of your senpai now.
Thank you.
It was super chat, girl.
Stitch wasn't the first one.
I think it was, it was definitely not Stitch who did the,
like, I know what you guys are talking about.
Like, you know, like they have someone behind the screen and
then he talks to you in person.
He's not the first one in the Disneyland, for Stitch.
I'm trying to remember which one.
The turtle, yeah, was it Crash?
Yeah.
Crash, it was Crash first, then Stitch.
A Crush.
For you.
It's your own mud for the camera.
If you like, you can practice taking a picture of me.
Was Crush after Stitch?
And you can take my picture.
Okay.
to talk to you.
Whoa, fold my feet.
It's magic.
Whoa, I have a camera.
Okay, I will say, like, press R and use...
Oh, okay.
What?
W-A-S-C?
Focus.
Focus M.
This is what he reminds me of.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Smartphones were around?
Oh, my God.
Yay!
The youngsters were 2002 and finding memos 2003.
But what about the park rides?
I don't know.
And we're talking about the park rides of the...
Where the interactive park rides.
Wait.
Maybe we can get them from the shops.
Oh, wait.
He just sounds like...
He does sound like Sonic, too.
You're right.
I wonder if that's the voice actor of Sonic.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's glowing.
Oh, there's a photo.
Wait, I want to take a photo.
of this wait how do I oh hey if you see a hidden Mickey oh
with Walt yeah I get to take a photo with Walt Disney all
right hey if you see a hidden Mickey be sure to use your
camera when you get photo Donald Donald where did Donald go
Donald Donald?
Wait.
Donald's gone.
I see Goofy, though.
I'll take further with Goofy.
Goofy, Goofy, Goofy.
Goofy.
It won't work yet.
You gotta go get the right album first.
What?
It's awesome in the shops.
What do you...
I have to buy an album from...
Oh my god.
Welcome to Disneyland.
They're like, you can't take that on your phone.
You don't have the right album.
I'm like, it's my phone.
It's, bro, what do you mean?
I need a bio, right?
It's my phone.
Just like, it's so accurate.
I'm so immersed right now.
That's how they get you.
I know, guys, I'm so immersed right now.
I'm not allowed to take photos unless I have the correct
album, even though I own my phone.
If you do, if you break the Disney rules, they're going to
be like, gonna get you gonna be locked up in disney jail oh
okay we're gonna shoot fireworks
yeah it's like being in the real disneyland creating a
fireworks show for everyone to enjoy all right
huh are they are they enjoying my flower show Oh, I have to
pop the flower.
Oh, my, these, oh, I will say this is so hard to control.
This is, it's so, what the, this is, oh my God.
I don't even, how am I controlling this?
Like, please.
Okay.
Oh, my God, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Oh, my God.
It's like, it's, it's almost like Connect Game was not built
for mouse and keyboard.
I, I don't know.
It's almost, it's, oh my god, okay, we got it.
Yay.
God, why is it so sensitive?
Okay.
Wait, I can move with my mouse and, oh my god, it was like,
press W-O-S-D.
And I was like, okay, you can control it with your mouse.
You can, okay, that's fine.
I figured it out.
You apparently can control it with your fucking mouse.
need to use your fucking WASD.
As a child, it's supposed to control.
Okay, nice, secret.
Yes, the mouse works.
You don't need to use WASD.
Press space.
Oh, new file works.
Is it more expensive?
Alright, nice.
Yay!
I did this.
A child did this.
You didn't tell this is dated because now Disney just used
drones.
Disney has stopped using.
They stopped using fireworks.
They just used drones now.
I would assume it's just cheaper than fireworks.
Because you can just reuse drones.
You literally just charge the drones.
Yeah, they use people, a lot of amusement parks just use
drones for like, for, uh, firework shows.
They do fireworks, but they also do like drone shows more.
I assume, yeah, I assume it's like cheaper to clean up too.
Yeah.
Yeah, I used to live next to an, uh, when I lived in China,
I used to live next to an amusement park in, in, uh, I don't
even know my telling, talking about, okay, so, I, it's
called like Happy Valley and like my grandparents, because I
live with my grandparents, and they live next to a Chinese
amusement park called Happy Valley, and every night at 9 p
.m., they would release the fireworks every fucking night.
And we were literally next tour to Happy Valley every night.
9 p.m.
out here.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I don't mind talking about, like, because, like, I moved out
of there looking years ago.
And, like, they sold the house, so, like, it's not, like,
I'm going back.
It's 9 p.m.
What an amazing show.
I'm sure...
Hey, I get my free fireworks show every day.
yeah it's cool after like you know it's cool for the first
week guys not even the first it's cool for the first day but
when it happens every day at 9 p.m sharp it suddenly gets a
little less cool and then i lived there for like two to
three years every day 9 p.m for two to three years i can't
even go to if i'm super tired doesn't matter people be like
boom boom boom it's just it's just my alarm clock a
backwards alarm clock yeah reverse alarm clock that's why
that's why amusement parks in america are so unless you live
in the disney hotelers i know there's like there's
apparently a gated community in one of the disneyland parks
i know some people are like wow dokey you know so much about
this disneyland It's because I used to watch like TPN videos
and shit because it's so interesting where they do like
animatronic failures And I would watch like other things
about like Disney parks because or like not just Disney
parks, but amusement parks too But they have a gated
community in one of the Disneyland parks
Wait, how did Mickey get here?
Would you mind finding goofy and taking his picture for me?
But yeah, usually Disney that's why Disney is so far away
from anything too Five yeah
yeah okay gotta find his girlfriend his eternal girlfriend
minnie got break up with him he's leading you on you've been
dating for how long now minnie and he hasn't popped the
question minnie think of it this way how many weddings have
you seen at disneyland and she he's still he's still just a
boyfriend
never gonna get that ring mini you gotta leave him he
doesn't appreciate you girl
almost a hundred years of dating now and he still hasn't
popped the question mini that's a red flag that's a that's a
red flag mini where am i supposed oh there's uh where does
he want where does some magic want to take me To Goofy?
But I already...
What do you want, Goofy?
I love to pose for a picture.
But I already took a picture of...
Oh, another one?
Ain't it?
Yeah!
Oh, I got the album!
I see, I didn't have to buy it.
I didn't have to buy the goddamn photo album.
He almost got me.
He had on the Matterhorn.
And he won't take any photos without his lucky hat.
If you want his picture...
Parent Donald, who's a divorced dad?
When the fuck was Donald?
the divorced dad.
Huey, Dewey, and Louie isn't even his.
They're like his nephews.
Ha-pa!
Good luck, pal.
Because no one's better at finding stuff than you.
No one.
Yeah?
That's funny.
Ha-ha!
They're so goofy, goofy.
What am I supposed to do with these, like, this virtual
currency?
It's not even real.
Alright, this way.
Yeah, after, yeah, Goofy, no, Goofy's not a divorced dad,
his wife is, guys, his wife is fucking dead, like, he's not
divorced, he literally, Pluto!
I was such a, I was such a little shit as a, as a kid, I
told you guys the story, but when I was in, like, Hong Kong
Disneyland, there was Pluto, and they had, like, a buffet, a
nice, fancy buffet, Pluto came to visit me, and it was my
birthday, And then my friend was with me too.
I invited my friend to Hong Kong Disneyland and then we're
like Pluto.
Why aren't you talking Pluto, huh?
Why aren't you talking?
My friend started like I'm so sorry to the cast member there
that had to put up with us little shits Oh, we're like come
on Pluto talk.
Why aren't you talking Pluto?
I'm sorry, I'm sorry I'm sorry the cast that had to feel of
us.
But we were we were children, okay?
Yeah, but we wanted him to bark.
We're like, Pluto, bark for us, Pluto.
And then my friend was, like, touching the inside of his
mouth and was like, come on, Pluto, why aren't you barking?
Why can't you speak?
And then another cast member, another, I think it was like,
Goofy came over to save him.
And just, like, just, like, try to save him and stuff.
And then we started bullying Goofy instead.
Pluto behind the mask.
All right.
Give me a head!
Your dog's got to look up for each other.
Yay!
Bro, if that's a real fucking cast member that licked my
head, the parents will not be happy.
Yay!
That's what I'm gonna do.
Yay, Pluto!
Yay!
Dance dog dance for our entertainment Yay Yay All right now
sign my autograph Here you can use a pen right
There's autograph done Autograph done Yeah I paid $100 I
better get my immersion I better get this better be a real
fucking dog Let's give me a hug It's a big-ass dog, though.
Why is Paloo so damn big?
Because I'm a fucking child!
I'm pretty sure a golden retriever is just as tall as a
little girl.
Like...
I think you guys forgot playing as a fucking little girl.
Yeah, he's as big as Donald.
Guys, dogs are supposed to be bigger.
or as big as a duck.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, hey, there's a...
We're a space mountain.
Wait, where is Minnie anyway?
Wait, where is the magic thing taking me?
I'm glad that they...
Oh, it's tomorrow, then.
I'm glad that they have the yellow spray paint for me so I
can know where to go.
Oh, there's no way!
Snow White!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, Snow White!
I hope so!
It's Disneyland!
Other than Paris Disneyland though, apparently Paris
Disneyland is not looking so good right now.
Hello!
Snow White!
Can you sign my book?
My name is Snow White.
I'm very pleased to meet you.
I once went, when I was a kid, I dressed up at Snow White
for Halloween.
Yay, patty cake, patty cake.
My baker's dead.
Make me a banana.
I don't remember any of the children rhymes when you do
patty cake.
Let's dash, no way.
Yeah.
I think, like, people are always on strike in France.
Oh, nuts.
We don't have the right autograph.
No!
Oh, can you just sign in my blitz?
Don't have Mickey World.
No, I swear.
I won't tell Mickey, please.
All right, at least I'll get a hug.
Next, see, they give us a super chat.
Really, can I get another hug then?
Yeah, Mickey sees off.
Yeah.
Oh, my God, she did a little curtsy.
I think I went to Disneyland Paris, and I think my
favorite...
My favorite part about Disneyland Paris was when you go
under the castle and you can actually see the dragon under
the castle that shit was cool It freaked me.
I was very scared, but I think like Thinking back that shit
was really cool.
Yay, someone dropped free money.
Captain Hawk Hello, Captain Hawk You have the honor of
meeting Captain Hawk.
Yeah
Salute oh my god He knighted me.
I'm a sir dokeybird now Yeah, we're jigging
Nice Hey, we didn't get the right book yet.
Oh my god
Why not what kind of hug you can I show you affection?
He's like please I can't Can't be cancelled okay they're
cute they're so that's so cute peter pan wait i want oh my
gosh peter pan's play i heard they um uh what's it called um
they like refurbished it and everything
i have no idea why sonic is here but he keeps gatekeeping my
my photos it's like in new york city where um you're not
allowed to take photos of mascots are to try to, like,
harass you for money.
Yeah, I have a super fast pass.
My parents paid an extra $500.
Tinkerbell!
Hello, Miss Tinks.
I love the fairy stories, like the original fairy books that
they wrote, the spin-off books they wrote for Tinkerbell.
I have the original hardcover of it with the bird oh of
course tinkerbell can teach you to teach me how to fly oh my
god here we go here we go yeah i'm playing with all my
emotions right now i have way too many i think there's like
20.
what's this what is this oh i'm gonna learn how to fly you
could tell You can tell I'm a big booty.
Oh shit.
This is the face of a girl with big booty.
There we go.
Let's grab the coins that people in London left out.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
Corns!
Oh shit.
I missed the Bitcoins there.
This isn't London.
It's Disney's London, guys.
It's Walt's Walt's Vision of London.
Yeah!
I can't believe people would leave all these coins.
down here in London.
Alright.
Use boost to get for it.
Can I slam myself on the pull?
Oh!
I feel like rest in peace.
The child just didn't make it.
It's the Puggy Peter Padrat.
There you go.
Yeah!
We got it.
Oh my god.
That reminded me of like...
Guys, remember the...
Oh wait, wait.
Nevermind.
I forgot what I was gonna say.
We'll never know.
You remember what, Toki!
Remember what?
Yeah.
We'll never know.
I'm gonna grab all these coins
Oh my god, it's the classic Also, by the way, we might not
play the Empress games Because apparently everyone was
telling me that I might get Might get YouTube, like the
YouTube guys might not like it So we're swapping games for
the Empress game on Saturday Don't do it, Toki, no.
Like the Walter White gift in the car in the window is like,
Toki, no, no, don't do it.
You might get striped by YouTube.
Toki, no.
So we're going to change it.
Yay, I know this place from Kingdom Hearts.
Yay!
We made it.
What took you so long?
I was grabbing all the loose chains.
I know just where to find Captain Hook.
We're off to Neverland.
Second star to the right and straight on to the mark.
Star Fox, if it was good.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Remember to me, I am not a Disney show.
Mr. Walt did not pay me to say that.
All right, nice.
All right, I leave now.
Oh, it's called your...
Was it your royal empress or something?
I'll get out That's crazy that there's still like a loading
time It's fine Oh wait I wanted to take a picture of Where
the fuck am I supposed to?
Okay I need to look at my map I need to look at my park map
Wait adventure journal What's this?
Oh Help Mickey complete a photo album Find Donald's Okay I
need oh it's the Matterhorn Oh that's the Yeti thing Okay
that's it Show on map.
Where is it?
Where's the Matterhorn?
Wait, where am I?
Okay, that's Pixie Hollow.
Wait, no!
Wait, where am I going?
Okay, no, I don't need to go to Pixie.
Oh my god, there's so many games.
Wait, wait, this is literally, like, giving this to a child
is cheaper than Disneyland.
Wait, this is so much better.
Yeah.
So, fun fact.
Apparently they fucked up the Matterhorn when they added the
Yeti.
Like whenever the Yeti move, the Matterhorn was slowly,
slowly and slowly breaking down.
Like the actual structure was like weakening every time the
Yeti was being used.
That is actually crazy.
So like if that's why like they had to stop the animatronic
because every time he moves, he's literally destroying the
fucking ride.
He fixed it now apparently.
Yeah, they fucked up the build on it.
So, like, it was actually, like, destroying the support
structure.
Is it that's the one in...
Aren't they all Matterhorns?
Or is it a different...
Or is it, like, a different name for it?
Because I know, like, I know they all...
He had the Yeti.
Where's Galaxy?
I don't think Galaxy Edge is...
It's in...
It was there in 2000.
What was this game?
When did this game come out?
The Connect is old as fuck.
I don't even know.
I don't need to go to the Matterhorn.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh my god.
Look at all that fucking...
Wait.
Aurora's here.
And Cinderella.
Cinderella.
Oh my gosh.
Was Cinderella 3?
With the song.
Yeah.
It's a similar ride.
Oh there's the Matterhorn.
There it is.
Do they accept?
Oh, there's Pixie Hollow.
Okay, no, I have to go find Donald's hat.
Cinderella 3 was so good.
I love the song that the little mice sang.
I forgot how it goes, but it was one of my favorite songs.
It's so dumb.
Let's see.
Oh, hey!
There's the beast!
Kill the beast!
Okay, I won.
Bonjour!
Don't worry.
Your human self is uglier.
You're proud of me!
Thank you.
He's proud of me!
Wee-wee.
Yeah, the Yadda yadda take apart the entire mountain, and
they're just like, no, we won't do that.
We'll just, like, turn it off.
You might have destroyed the support structure of the...
like the mountain a little bit but as long as we don't turn
it on it'll be fine yeah give me a hug
he's french guys how did you not the entire movie is based
in france guys i literally was like bonjour bonjour bonjour
bonjour bonjour hello what the fuck do you mean he's french
the opening song.
Wait, I hear the Mad Hatter.
Oh, wait, but we have to go to Mad Hatter Hatter Hatter.
It's like my day is ruined.
I can't believe the beast is fresh.
They're all French.
I need to use the bathroom here back.
It's rumored to pee before you go on a ride.
That is so true.
Because you're going to be in that line for like three
hours.
Sigil, Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ryu, Mike, AK, Papa, Smurf, Mennie, Alan, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's go do that Bob sled.
Let's get Donald's lean left or right.
What happens when I bump into it?
I mean, it's a kid's game.
It should be fine, right?
Yay!
This does not look very safe for children, Mickey!
Mr. Mouse.
What the fuck is it?
So Richo, Wilhams, Wilhams, scream.
Sorry about that.
Say, are you ready to hit the slope?
Yeah!
Yeah, Kofi!
Hold on tight now.
This wind will blow your ears back.
Yeah!
We'll have...
What happens?
Oh my god!
I'm okay.
I got wait, will it be Sonic where okay.
I lose points.
Okay.
Yeah Why I don't think this ride has safety inspections.
Yes, I don't think this ride is made for children All right.
Yeah, it's okay, but that's okay.
My parents signed a form before I got on this ride And so
And I think it was a I think it was a good forum, right?
Did you see nothing to it?
Don't worry, they agreed to the terms of service on Disney
Plus, so I was allowed to ride on this ride.
Oh no, they're easier to get me.
Oh no, not the Yeti.
Not the abominable snow, man.
I'm sure Donald's had us up here on this mountain somewhere.
What the fuck are trying to kill me?
Oh my god!
Guys, maybe we should have built a ride in their home guys
maybe maybe we shouldn't have built a ride there oh no the
ride's gonna collapse wait where yeah I could jump this
entire time yeah oh fuck you oh my god it's alright kids
don't get concussions right
Oh, bye Goofy.
Don't worry, it's Disney Magic.
It's like, what happened to the other kids that took this
ride, I wonder.
All right, nice.
All the coins I need for...
All the coins I need for my photo album, too.
It's all staged.
It's all scripted.
Goddamn mouse.
It's like those singers that like lip sync to during
concerts.
Like, I know what you are.
Oh my god, goodbye, goofy.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, that scared me.
I thought I was like, I did not run into the fucking gap.
Eh.
I did it.
I guess when you're playing on the connect, you're like
actually leaning left and right.
Where you're like, wow.
Wow.
Don't worry.
I'm being immersive.
When I go right, I leave right.
Whoa
Yeah I'm drifting Sure is quiet here.
Hope there ain't any yet.
No Oh
my god.
Whoa Oh, it's like a different game too because there's like
snow buff but i just got the i grabbed donald's hat i gotta
know i can't be there's lore in this game i need i need to
grab donald's hat so i can buy more photo albums so i can
take more pictures and then i die at the end it's okay my
parents agree to terms of surface on disney plus so i should
be taking care of right Oh, where'd Donald go?
Oh, hey.
Oh, can I take a picture of this?
Oh, I can say hi to it.
Take a picture of this plant.
It's a beautiful plant.
Oh, yeah.
And apparently, Disney parks are supposed to smell like
cotton candy.
They literally have these little scent things scattered
around the Disney park.
And then, where the fuck is Donald?
To make sure, like, things smell like cotton, like cotton
candy and flowers.
It's a small world.
We have to go to smallbutton.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's a small world after all.
It's a small world after all It's a small world I'm always
afraid of it's a small world Because I feel like there's so
many animatronics there And I feel like if they come to life
I would actually die
Do we have to go?
It's literally I feel like it's a small world It's literally
the ride where there's no wait time Like no one wants to go
to it's like Parents who go Parents who take their kids to
it's a small world When they want to fucking sit down
Because there's never a line for this fucking ride I don't
think you're coming.
Oh, yeah!
What is this?
It's alive!
This is not as a small world.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
This is just hard labor.
Oh, hey, it's...
Oh, it's the Wild West!
And here we are in the desi plains and rocky valleys of the
American Old West.
Let's see what dance step they have to teach you.
Whoa, why don't you teach me, little kid?
Oh!
It's a small world.
After all, it's a small world.
After all, it's a small, small world.
Oh my God, it's literally a rhythm game.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no Nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no
It's a small world, after all, money!
The traditional gritty.
Put your hands up!
Put your hands up for small world!
Raise the roof!
Raise the roof, girl!
Yeah, it's a small world always freaks me out, even as an
adult.
Because, like, I always feel like I could get murdered
there.
Like, the animatronics and it's a small world, they just...
There's just something ain't right.
Like, it just...
It just feels like there's something weird going on, you
know?
I don't know how to explain it.
What the fuck?
Oh, where am I?
This is the entirety of Europe?
In India?
Wait, no, Russia.
That's the Russia place.
I thought that was the Taj Mahal at first.
The dancers will teach you some new dance moves.
Just follow along.
Oh, we're in Europe now.
Yeah, we're in Europe land.
I don't know.
There's just something about the animatronic.
that just feel there's just something feels off ah yes the
great british dance ah yes ah yes london teach england teach
me the great london dance the march
yes teach me how to walk
this feels more like a dance the other guy was just teaching
me to fucking walk.
March and red coat.
Ah, yes.
Thank you.
These are European representatives.
Okay, is this a real dance now?
Ah, yes.
The traditional English dance the bow.
Always remember to use this when you see your royal
highness.
Every Englander must know this.
Every British man must know this.
You see, that's a dance.
That's a dance here.
Every British kid needs to know how to walk and bow.
Alright, Mr. Europe man.
What's next?
Oh, oh, they're swapping.
exchanging oh they're just leaving this is a great place but
there's still more to see let's pull up the anchor and start
turning that lever oh but no more it was like three out of
four did i not march hard enough to unlock the goodbye
europe land really that was their chosen representative i
mean the girl was good but they really out of all the
europeans out there they chose the british man Oh, it's
Easter Islands!
The giant statues and incredible sea life of the Pacific
Islands are all right here.
Let's dance along with the children who live here.
Yeah!
Just the Brits and the Spaniards.
Is this Moana?
Banana, banana, no, no, no, no, no.
that's a dance but no no no no no no no no no no it's a
small world after all yippee it's pre-mawana
it's a small world after all it's a small world after It's a
small world after all It's a small world after all
Oh no no no no Oh my god yeah Shake those hips girl Yeah Oh
no no It's a small world after all Damn look at her ball
Oh I shook those hips.
Hips don't lie.
Let's head out to the ocean again.
Time to start turning the lever.
I don't, but I don't, but I don't know.
All right, time to turn on the lever.
Where is it gonna take me?
Still haven't found Minnie Mouse yet.
She's hiding.
Shh.
She's hiding from Mickey.
I'm like, where the fuck?
Oh, there it is.
Join the happiest cruise I ever sailed.
I want to go on actually I low-key really want to go on a
Disney cruise but like the really the newest one where they
have like the Avengers now too there's like Corel de Ville
Lounge looks really cool March white boy March I just yeah
let's go
All right.
I still love that for the entire representatives of of your
plan is the UK and the Spaniards and the UK all he gave us
was the bow and the march I was like what about the Russian
dance we could have there's so many dances out there and
bowing?
Oh, you need.
Do I see I'm hungry?
What do you eat?
Um, in the spirit of England, you should get baked beans.
It truly is a small world.
Oh my god, get pin badges too.
I gotta go pin trading.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's randomized.
What she wants you get oh my god wait have you played this
game a lot wait how do you know her current voice actor
versus helman's really the that's crazy you would think like
you think like disney would stop that you know oh hey it's
the rabbit i'm late i'm late i'm late i'm so late hello you
would think that disney would not allow that to her grace
her majesty the queen Like, half are locked in contract.
Gongo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know the Minnie and Mickey Mouse voice actors are actually
married now.
He's like, I'm late, but I'll shake your hand.
Nya!
He's like, please put me down, child.
Please.
I'm late.
Hey, we didn't get the right book yet.
Oh, my God.
We can swap magic coins for the right one.
I don't know.
Alright, let's leave.
Check my hand again.
This is a strong child.
I demand uppies.
I don't care.
I want to give you uppies.
How do I go to Donald Duck?
That sucks.
I don't know where the photo album is.
Oh my god, I'm such a rich child.
But I feel like the conversion rate is like, Oh hey, there's
two in town.
Area!
I'll come back when I find a photo album So I can get it all
done at once.
I feel like the conversion rate is like Zimbabwe dollars.
So it's like a thousand, a thousand Mickey Mouse coins Is
like one cent.
One American dollar.
One American cent.
We're saying, Daisy!
Daisy!
Hello there, miss.
I'm Daisy.
pleased to meet you oh whoa that'll be thrilled hurry over
and give him his hat zimbabwe that's kind of specific
because i remember watching a video where i think that that
what was it zimbabwe was like the first one of those like
viral videos one of the early uh she's like please please
what do you want like why are you just afk um i don't
remember i don't remember what the video was exactly but it
was talking about like the currency rates yeah oh did they
use the america yeah the That, yeah.
That's where the $2 trillion note came from.
Oh, wait, what?
She kicked me out!
She kicked me out because I was AFK!
Yay, hyperinflation!
How fun!
That's good for them, though, now that they're using the
American dollar.
The inflation was really bad over there.
I mean, they literally had $2 trillion note.
Yay!
Yeah, Daisy is like no time for AFKers.
Why?
I thought you'd never ask.
Yeah.
Why is she using my...
What the fuck?
It's a hardcover book.
Thanks again.
Okay.
Hug time.
Yay!
Ha-pa!
All right.
Exit time.
Let's see, uh...
Oh, I forgot to give you a photo!
Wait, wait, we gotta take a photo!
Oh, well, Donald be thrilled!
Hurry over and get- Oh, okay.
Wait, I wanna take a photo.
Wait, how do I take a- Uh...
Alright, there you go.
Photo?
Are you- Oh my god!
Okay, how about this?
Can I take a photo of a truck?
Am I?
Do I have permission to take a photo?
Okay, at least I have permission to take a photo of a
fucking five truck.
Alright.
At least that's good.
I can't even take a photo with Daisy.
She's not allowed to be on the same photo album as Mickey
Mouse.
That's fuck.
Where's Donald?
Donald!
I really want to go to I don't want to...
Oh, I don't want to...
She has a gift for me Cinderella I don't want to I do want
to go back to Disneyland one day Because I haven't been in
Disneyland in like fucking years But not I don't know which
Disneyland though I really okay but I really want to go to
Shanghai Disneyland because I heard like it's super crazy
Shanghai Disneyland because it's like oh hey Donna Because
they because it's like their newest Disneyland they up They
had like really crazy modern rides and stuff Really crowded
like look a huge fucking lines and everything Hello Donald I
have your hat
I heard it's incredibly crowded the lines Yeah, the Pirates
line is crazy.
You know Jack Sparrow is like super popular in Asia Vote for
Donald!
Yeah!
A vote for Donald is a vote for world peace.
I'm not...
Donald has some...
There's Mickey.
Oh wait, there's Mickey's like right next to us.
That's nice.
Oh, they're all here!
Wait, where's Minnie?
Minnie!
I'm pleased to meet you too!
I like all the pictures you've collected.
Really?
Why is she like sigh-eyeing me?
Like, she's like...
I don't know if she's talking.
He's like sigh-eyeing me.
She's like judging.
She's actually, look at that!
Look at that!
She's judging me!
But she talks!
Like, mm-hmm, are you really...
Are you really wearing that?
She's like, really wearing that outfit?
Okay.
How bad?
Yeah, there's something weird about Minnie's model.
I think, I don't know.
Maybe it's the head.
There's something off.
There's something really off about her model.
My signature?
Yes, please.
Oh, I think it would be my pleasure.
She kissed it.
I have her DNA.
Yay!
Oh, my God.
I have her DNA now.
Yeah, she complimented me now.
Now, did you get a compliment from Minnie Mouse, guys?
I did get cloned her now.
Yay.
And I got, guys, whenever I hug her, I'll grab a clip of her
hair, too.
Don't worry.
Ooh, snip, snip.
Grab a clip of her hair and I have her saliva.
Toodaloo.
Oh, wait, wait.
I can take a picture.
Picture?
Oh, my God.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
But, I want to look at my autograph book.
I want to look at their autographs.
Oh, gosh.
Love Kofi.
Your pal Mickey Mouse.
That, there's no way he, I, I, he just did a paw print.
Bro, what the fuck?
Bro, what is his paw's shape like?
What are his paws fucking shape?
like he slapped his paw in the book and then there's a bone
and a heart in there there's like yeah I need to do it he
didn't even use a pen I didn't even see a pen oh yeah I got
the gosh you really came through for me pal the photo albums
complete literally his paw has like a built-in pen you know
what I got an idea since you help me so much I'd like you to
give the album to me.
Me?
Oh my gosh, you'll think it's from me.
I'll take all the credit.
Yeah.
Bye-bye.
What the fuck?
Okay, wait, guys, guys, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Guys, guys.
Hey, pal.
Have you given Minnie her surprise yet?
Okay, look at I can't wait to hear what she says.
Look at, look at, like, the texture on his head when I
leave.
Look at that.
Like, what is that?
What is, it's like Play-Doh.
Are you made a Play-Doh?
Mickey, it's like Play-Doh, and you scrape the Play-Doh
right Mickey I thought you were real Mickey I thought yeah
like what is what is this texture like you would think it'd
be like I don't know more smooth or some shit or like fur
but like like this is a copy pasta game it's like played and
guys there's no way he's not real but he's talking to me
though but yeah it looks like rubber it looks like he's made
of rubber or some shit oh is it cuz it's rubber and oh my
okay I don't think they thought too far about that I was
like always cuz like rubber added rubber hose but then I'm
like there's no I refuse to believe the dead slot that far
for
me why does she always look down when she talks to me like
yay yay
I did it!
Alright, what is there to...
What do I have to do now, Adventure Journal?
How am I supposed to buy...
Oh, no current adventures.
I need to buy new photo albums so I can take photos with all
of my Disney stars!
I just have Disneyland landmarks!
It's not fair!
Okay, I gotta...
Alright, look at the park map.
Where the fuck are the shops?
How can I indulge in capitalism?
This does not help.
He said there's like, oh, there it is.
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's all the way in the front.
Okay, go to entrance.
I fast travel.
Thank God I paid $300 to be able to fast travel.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Is that the mouse?
Okay.
All right, here we are.
Hi.
I would like to go to the shop.
and partaken raising the disney economy i've got plenty to
choose wait are there's merchandise what's merchandise
there's a chip and tail pin we gotta grab that yes please
you made yeah i got the chip and tail pin it doesn't do
anything it just it just won it oh my god just left okay sir
sir i actually need to buy more stuff always good to see a
good customer Oh, yeah, I can get autographs.
Are you fucking kidding?
There's a book for, like, each movie.
Like, what is this?
Okay, Heroes, Winnie the Pooh, Allison, Wonderland, Toy
Story, Trickster.
Okay, we'll grab the princess one.
Alright, it makes sense because there's a lot of princesses.
And then...
And then we'll grab...
Oh, my God.
Okay, wait, toys big and small.
We'll grab big.
all things okay this the beast okay paloo we'll grab that
they're bleeding me dry welcome to Disneyland we have to pay
parking ticket food take food water uh the tickets
themselves um um hotels travel souvenirs get the villains
too much for shopping with us all right is there anything
love them here oh my and then i have to buy the photo albums
too are you fucking okay it's okay it's okay um but there's
only two all right oh my god it's only for main street it's
only what do you mean it's only for me i can't take photos
beyond main street okay we got
$5,000 churros.
Yeah, $5,000 churros.
I've got plenty to choose from.
What is this?
That really was the perfect choice for you.
Oh, apparently the Bayou Adventure for Tiana, apparently
it's already, like, breaking down.
And the ride has been out for one year, and the animatronics
are already breaking down.
I thought that was fucking crazy.
Apparently there was, like, a very important, like, ride, a
moment in the Bayou Adventure and then they like didn't have
it on.
It was like a literal TV screen too and they couldn't get to
work for half a year.
Yeah, it was it replaced Splash Mountain but even then like
it's already, the fact that it's already breaking down after
after like a year is crazy.
Wow, I can take a picture I know, I'll take a picture of
What is this The plaza in Let me take a picture of a regular
fucking building I guess I know I couldn't understand I was
like, how the fuck is the TV broken for half a year It's not
even an animatronic It's literally like a TV part I assume
Toy Story Buzz Lightyear is in here Oh Yeah, Plaza is in the
best character.
Buzz!
Hello, Buzz!
Tim Allen!
Greetings, young citizen.
You are now a Star Command cadet under the direction of Buzz
Lightyear.
I'm Mr. Buzz Lightyear, anime.
Anime to show.
The evil Emperor Zerg's been cited in this quadrant.
So Star Command has authorized me to issue protective
weaponry.
Because this is the actual Buzz light year not the not the
toy version of him obviously yeah because he's a real person
the toy was based off of a real man oh my god i got the
blaster when you equip the blaster yeah there's anatomy in
the show you have to do is a because that's what the toy was
based out of a space ranger only uses such a weapon an
extreme emergency he gave us a gun yeah guys where do think
the toy came from and always show respect to the citizens
you were sworn to protect excellent i see you're ready for
the next step in your training yeah we test your reflexes
and build your stamina oh what you've got oh god okay what
oh okay yeah i was like am i flexing okay yeah big guy Punch
him so much about pants on kicks That's it Just don't forget
to breathe Of course It was a really good show It was like
the only There was only one Adaptation Of Buzz Lightyear And
it was that no other ones That's happening me I showed great
promise He's gonna recruit me To the army now bro fist yo
bro oh my god he truly is a bro
oh that's cute i like that yeah it's so weird that they
never did another adaptation of buzz buzz light year other
than the animated show i know right yay Yes, your affection
is duly noted.
You know, they give us Super Chat the good thing.
Yeah, it was a fun series.
Don't forget to obtain your Space Ranger uniform, Cadet.
Until next time.
The Zerg plans to invade the system.
Okay, so...
So, hypothetically, if Disney made a...
How do I...
Yeah?
Take the shot.
Doki, take the shot.
Where the fuck am I supposed to shoot anyway?
Where do I shoot this?
I am Buzz Lightyear.
I call him in peace.
You get a one from Cinderella.
How do I?
How do I shoot my gun?
The shot that could end the war.
Do it, Doki.
Take the shot save the world the shot that will save the
world I can't even take a shot anywhere I don't it's like
you could only use it in certain places where can I use it
the shot heard around the world I assume it's in here but oh
we're not allowed in here the blast area yet no he said he
said oh here do I shoot it he said I could take the shot in
like certain areas.
I won't say a thing.
But like, what area would that be?
There was a hidden Mickey?
Oh, there's a Platte Auto Blaster, though.
And beyond!
Okay, so
um...
So basically, hypothetically, if Disney remade Buzz
Lightyear into a 3D film, um, basically they said that
emperor zerg is literally buzz light year from the future
because every time he travels into space like he's sent on a
mission and every time he travels in space like uh 20 plus
years pass or some shit so by time he comes back like his
best friend is dead and then he keeps traveling in the
future more and more and more to the point where like
to join the army yeah they enlisted me let's go and then
they found the plot twist was that Emperor Zerg was actually
Buzz Lightyear from the heroic rescue it's dangerous but we
have an advantage and that's why people are like what the
fuck we'll go in fast duck under Zerg's radar and rescue the
enemy okay I'm not gonna read your comment I was like yeah
that's funny you may have lost the no it's it's literally
him oh my god oh my god i'm literally i'm literally a ranger
they enlisted a child for war well in the in the old version
it's his it's his dad like the classic story but but in the
3d film in the 3d adaptation it's Oh, I have to reload.
Reload!
In the 3D film, it's him.
You know, Buzz, it'd be cool if you helped out.
That's alright.
There you go, I did it.
Yeah, the original is a Star Wars reference because it was
made...
It was...
Buzz, like, you know, it was like a parody of Star Wars, in
a way.
Like, the...
Not, like, full parody, but it was, like, you know...
They're saying, like...
Uh, you know how like in the original toy story it was like
Woody was like his favorite toy and the Star Wars came out
So they're like, what's next year?
Yeah, we have a lot of sci-fi stuff.
Yeah, including Star Wars Oh,
I'm targeting the arm.
Don't worry You're now an amputee All right Oh shit, I'm
okay.
We're doing it.
Make a kid do it.
Make a kid do a man's job.
Let's go.
Well.
Yeah.
I'm having trouble apparently controlling my my blasters mr.
Buzz Lightyear.
It's okay that that I'm literally like killing the animal
life life platforms in this planet The indigenous like
plants in this Yeah
They didn't even do anything they were just existing Bye
idiots aren't even doing anything this is for star command
you won't understand no survivors
how do i keep them busy do i just zap them like oh i do i do
i just zap them
i was only following orders I've got this.
Only slightly painful.
Come on.
Yeah, we did it.
All right, back to the pie.
With democracy.
Why?
What did I do, guys?
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kids would love this compliment butchering of everyone's
child.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What did I do?
Yes, I'm innocent.
I was just using my blaster
All right, I want to change the sense.
I don't keep changing it, but for some reason the sense is
like sometimes it's like super fast And then suddenly it's
like so slow
Okay, I think that should be better.
I want to use my gun
It should be a place for me to shoot it.
He said it works for certain areas.
What area is it?
To aim like.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Save the planet.
I am aiming.
Oh my god.
It just says aim.
How do I shoot?
I just want to use my gun.
Oh, where is she?
Oh, wait.
Wait, they have...
I can, like...
I saw the Buzz Lightyear uniform.
I could buy.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I could be a fish suit.
Wait.
Oh.
You're a Dessa, Princess Aurora.
Oh, I could be a princess.
Okay, but I could be a fish, though.
I'll complete our fish.
Oh my god, it's from the Finding Mimo ride.
Okay, what does this do?
I'm a fish.
Oh, I wish I could be our fish princess.
I could be Cinderella.
Oh, I should buy the autograph books.
I need to keep buying them.
I have enough money for it.
Look at me go.
Always a pleasure to see you again.
Okay, we gotta keep buying photo albums and indulge in.
Thanks so much for shopping with us.
Alright, there we go.
I haven't enough money.
I have money for days now.
Alright, we got all the autograph books.
We can now legally get their autographs.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
You have to go to the shop of each world so you can get
their photo.
How is there?
Three photo albums for one land.
Oh, but I got $6,000.
I've only got $66,000.
Oh, I can wear a hat, though.
Wait, I want to wear this hat.
Wait, what is this?
I do.
I know I do.
I do have wonderful taste.
How did you know?
Oh, yeah.
I want to keep the buzz hat.
Oh, my God.
There's a stitch hat.
Wait a minute.
minute wait say thank you but thank you mr disney what does
this look like oh my god dude i like how this fucking
stitches body it's like the fucking the half-life crab
literally
literally at a fucking half-life i'm getting so many ideas
from disney from mr disney thank you uh what else what
shirts do i have i like how this like a png screenshot It's
just my way and after all It's just my way and after all
Like the pants is just the regular pants That's not fair I
should be able to wear my fish suit On top of my On top of
my buzzlight
The witty shirt is scary Oh my guys which one Do I wear my
buzzlight gear hat Or my fish costume Which one is better I
like how the fish isn't even like, because it's based off of
the Finding Nemo, right?
But it's not even like any of the characters.
It's literally just a random ass fish.
The fish is insane.
It's like they're like, here's the Finding Nemo ride.
It's like based off of the Finding Nemo ride.
I'm like, it's just, it's not even any of the characters.
It's just a fucking random fish.
Well, dude, if Walt Disney hit it better.
There's a fourth stitch!
Where's stitch?
Oh my
god!
Take the shot.
Take the shot, Toki.
Okay.
Alright, let's take a photo, Toki.
No!
You be my Achi Baba!
Run!
Good!
The shot that is...
the ward don't keep taking you find lunch for stitch lunch
what the fuck why me feed stitch there's children everywhere
just eat one of them you need real kids are food let's dance
stitch yeah shake it like the king oh yeah he's like
obsessed with elvis presley oh my god we're doing it we're
doing the presley dance yeah
Please sign my book.
Fun for Stitch to sign book.
Yeah!
Tate book, Stitch done.
Got his autograph, guys!
Yay!
Very happy hug.
We got a hug!
Stitch starving!
The origin of the boo-boo- Honestly, you're not drugged.
Just keep your eyes peeled, and I'll give a shout if I- He
looked like madness level.
Very high.
Yay!
It's funny because, uh, what's it called?
The...
Look, there's one.
Told you we'd find them.
Oh, there's a food.
There's food already here.
Let's go.
Yay!
Is that it?
Oh, you need five burgers?
There it is.
Space Mountain!
What was that?
What was that story that always tells, like, Stitch plushies
and figurines and stuff?
I can't remember.
Literally, they made merch that's like Labubu adjacent.
He is literally the original Labubu.
Where are the burgers?
I'm gonna go to Space Mountain.
What was that store?
I can't remember.
sells a lot of like uh no that sells a lot of like um
plushies and merchant figures of stitch as well as like
zutopia and like other like sanrio stuff too what was it try
to remember they sell like a lot of like like it's very
similar it's like it's like it's like almost like popmart
but like it's like a the cat um the enemy brand of pop If
you go to Maniso, you can actually find, like, the
boo-boo-like stitch toys or stitch figures.
I'm not joking.
I'll show you guys one right now.
But after I do mission control, they're like the enemy brand
of Pop Mart.
They're like their rivals.
It's like McDonald's and Burger King.
Before, like, McDonald's won.
It's like Coke versus Pepsi.
wait why is this tron i'm in space mountain this is like
tron the tron bike rides in shanghai disneyland
welcome to your tour i will be your god this is not real
space mountain because there's no scary alien trying to kill
me I haven't seen one of those in here.
Hello?
Like, I was like, is he done?
Like, what is he trying to do?
Do a little fucking dance for me?
Oh shit, car crash.
Oh my god.
I don't think it was a good idea that I'm driving against
traffic.
It might not be the smartest thing I've done today.
Use the ship's laser to charge the game by shooting its
energy paths once charged yeah the game will greatly
increase the speed of objects that pass through it junk
coordinates receive do you know there's a jimmy fallon ride
on universal studios i know you're like how do you make a
ride out of that i know i watch a video of it and it's
barely a ride it's crazy they actually have a fucking Jimmy
Fallon ride.
But why?
Look, Carpool Karaoke was very popular, okay?
It was very, very popular.
Black holes are the most destructive forces in the universe.
It's literally like a ride taking you around New York City.
Like, that's the ride.
But like, they have Jimmy Fallon's face plastic.
around around it
yeah this is not i don't really feel the space mountain of
this where is the fucking crazy alien ghost that's trying to
kill me where is that
oh thank god okay nice this game surprisingly has a lot of
content i feel like i barely did anything thing in this
game.
Judging by the current velocity, with the continued use
of... Like, I barely met, like, everywhere.
Like, I feel like I've only met, like, 10% of the characters
in this game.
Alright, here we go.
Good job.
A bit more traffic than I would expect in hyperspace.
Impact report.
Minimal damage.
I saw someone said that you think Jimmy Fallon's kind of
bland, but, like, he just approved He's the perfect late
night host because he's bland.
He doesn't offend nor does he like give you anything, which
is perfect.
Because you're here for the guests, not like...
So then that's like great for like the guests he's
interviewing because you're there for them, not for him.
Because he's a host.
He's not the star.
That's why he's so famous.
That's why he has his own universal ride.
open space and we hit traffic yeah Conan was perfect though
yeah and then he got fired because he was the thing is
Fallon has no opinions that's why he's perfect Conan had too
many opinions and then he got fired
that's the issue for network executives they don't like that
they're like you have your own opinions
We need a yes, man.
And that's what Fallon is.
Good job.
Exiting hyperspace.
The comment field I'm detecting is massive.
Be alert.
Yeah, I know, like, Jayla, I know wanted to come back.
But still, he still, like, lost the show.
Like, even then, the network execs didn't really, like, give
him anything.
that he didn't really he didn't really treat him well after
the fact that he got like he lost his job he literally like
he literally like went into full depression mode right after
judging by your current velocity with a continued use yeah
and people forgot he after he got let go like he literally
locked himself in his home and didn't make a public
appearance for months like i was like is he okay like and
then when he finally made his public appearance you knew he
went like he was going through shit like it was like he was
like you had like a long ass beard and everything
like i remember reading like seeing the articles about that
Yeah, he was going through it.
Because it was literally his dream job.
And then he lost his dream job.
Yeah, he became a neat...
No, he actually did.
He actually became a neat.
For like a wow.
Because like, like, uh, replacing...
Like taking that...
What was it?
The late night show?
Tonight's late night show was like his dream.
His dream job.
Oh my god.
We're literally going through a space battle right now.
Yeah.
We did it.
We did Space Mountain.
There's something else I want to talk about before I did
Space Mountain, but I forgot.
I forgot what I wanted to talk about.
I got, I was thinking about like.
the the jimmy fallon ride but something else oh yeah i
wanted to show you guys the miniso the stitch labubu oh yeah
because you guys don't believe me okay stitch miniso it's
literally it literally looks like a labubu where is it i
need to find the perfect okay so there's several versions of
this they make a is just one thing.
The Stitch one has like so many versions of him.
But it literally looks like a Laboobu.
Oh, there's like, I like the street one.
The streetwear one is so cute.
I low-key, I low-key want the street look, the street one.
Yeah, it's literally a blue Laboobu.
Yeah, sure, yes.
Don't worry, Stitch.
I'll come.
I'll come over.
here it's I think it's a cuter lapubu but it's literally
like the same like concept like there's this one and then
there's this one and they sell this at miniso I want I want
the gangster stitch one I want the street one look at this
also I'm sorry but it's so weird that Angel is everywhere.
Like, I know, like, she's, like, the girl, like, girl
Stitch, like, the girlfriend of Stitch, but she's, like,
barely a character.
And they're, like, cousins.
Yeah, I didn't, but this, like, yeah, I want the gangsta
Stitch.
They're so cute.
But they have even more.
They have so many versions.
Yeah, there's so many versions of these, too.
Uh, okay, Stitch, I guess you're gonna starve.
I'm too, there's too many things to do with disneyland i'm
sorry stitch of course i used to watch the original tv show
lily on stitch it was one of my favorite shows back when
disney channel was oh it's the aliens of the claw hello
greetings we request your assistance no it has the same like
uh concept of a labubu doll like the hard plate for the face
and then the fluff like everything is fluffy like please
stop like see look at this it's literally the same concept
with the because the if you have a labubu it's like the face
plate is hard and then the the the paws and the hands are
also like hard plastic but everything else is like fluff but
they didn't do this until labubu became oh fuck no they
kicked me out i didn't initiate communication they did that
it was after labubu became popular that they started doing
it all right Yay!
Let's do it, everyone!
Oh my god!
Three high fives!
You want better than one high fives?
She dances, and so do we.
We're dancing!
Welcome to tomato farm, V!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay.
We have been chosen.
Hello.
Yes.
I have picked you.
Don't worry Thank you It is mine Here let's all have a hug
now Whoa whoa there I'm a child Whoa Oh my god like Do you
guys see it?
There's like reflections on my helmet There's way too much
There's way too much detail for what this game is Oh Goodbye
He doesn't want to see you I see Small All right, where do
we go?
Oh, wait, photo, photo!
I forgot to take the photo!
Okay, sorry, not...
Wait, that's not my...
That's not my camera?
Let's take a photo!
You have been chosen!
We have been chosen!
Yeah!
We've been chosen!
I chose you!
All right, what else?
things can i do here on disneyland oh it's auto auto pia
heard this rap isn't auto pia like really oh wait no you get
to have a little mini race right oh what's this a phone what
can i do with a phone
i take picture of the phone is that like a unique picture to
take it's like no not that when can i shoot my gun oh oh i
can i can shoot my gun in the in the red ones!
Free money!
Oh my god, free money!
This is where you shoot your gun!
Oh my god!
It's like when you like shoot the ATM for free money, guys.
You shoot the phone, you get- Oh, oh, there's target!
There's literally a fucking target.
What's this?
Oh, it's a mini-game!
I gotta test my FPS.
Pew, pew.
Oh, you're not supposed- Guys, did you know that skull...
Death skull means bad for some reason?
Okay.
Eh.
Don't shoot the death skulls.
Oh.
Bad balloon.
Oh shit, I almost shot it.
Oh my god, there's so many bad balloons.
Oh.
Yay!
We did it.
All right.
Five stars.
This was before AIM Labs was the thing.
Boot up Disneyland adventures to practice your aim.
Well, finding Nemo.
Let's find Nemo.
I'm dressed for it too.
This is this what Disneyland world is like and I'm loving
Chi Prime.
Thank you.
the super chat papa thank you thank you yeah but we're just
missing the the five dollar churros right now and the
popcorn buckets the fifty dollar popcorn buckets and the
five dollar churros and then this would be perfect yeah we
found him we found me why is me most so fucking big that is
not that that is not possible
It's the coolest place in the whole ocean.
Oh,
yeah, the $20 turkey legs.
That is terrifying.
In finding Nemo, if Nemo was actually that big.
I'll start counting.
I heard.
Because finding Nemo got so popular.
Oh my god, we're actually finding Nemo.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, we're finding me?
Am I hiding?
It's like, I'm hiding.
There's no way he knows I'm here.
Oh, it's finding me more, not finding me, not finding Doki.
He'll never know.
Wait, he found me?
How did he find me?
He has wall hacks.
Check his PC.
I guess I found him Oh yeah Oh I could be I could just chill
and grab shit
He's more funny Yeah I found him now I'm following a report
right now Okay we got it
Where am I?
Where am I, Mimo?
How did you find me?
You can't be like, you're good at this game.
I found you.
I can't believe it.
He's cheating.
I don't know how he's doing it, but I can tell he's
cheating.
Okay, there's no way he'll find me now.
I think this is the shittiest high.
spot yet like wait I blend right in guys I blend right in
there's no way he'll know have you ever seen a sea spot the
next place has tons of them Awesome, dude.
Adas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank God every time he counts, he poops out money.
Yep, I definitely am.
I gotta get my free money, though.
Okay, here.
Alright, we got here.
can you can you really that's right yeah that's right hey i
know another place it's got ancient ruins are we allowed
there is your dad gonna be okay with us there are you sure
here i go oh it's like atlantis still counting nine awesome
dude 16.
Gotta get my free money first, Mimo.
Seven, six.
Five.
There you go.
Can't see me, right?
Be very, very quiet.
I'm hiding.
Yeah!
Last game.
Last one.
Is Mimo stupid?
Guys, look.
His entire...
His entire siblings are dead, okay?
We gotta treat him well.
He literally lived because the shark saw his egg and was
like, I shouldn't eat that one.
There's something wrong with it.
The shark was like, there is no good nutritional value
eating this one.
Yay!
We got it!
I don't even remember what kind of animal, like what kind of
fish ate him.
It was a big ass fish though, like in his family.
Yes, use the...
Yes, use Mimo as...
As the fucking...
As like a crutch.
Like, Mimo's been through a lot already.
Oh, I didn't notice that little error I had.
of the the the tag sticking out why should i should pin that
down okay wait i should make a note of that to the rigor
about that about my the the earring tag coming out that
ain't good that's not supposed to happen all right i marked
it what the fuck i tabbed out and then my game is wait my
game's not full screen anymore let me fix that real quick
it's a magical tag where's my full screen hello yes oh my
god next time it launched are you fucking here okay whatever
we don't need it to be full screen um actually it was a
barracuda oh yeah i was gonna say ever when fighting me well
first came up um it was a big problem because everyone was
buying clownfishes.
And then it led to like clownfish being endangered because
of it.
Okay.
Oh, I met everyone.
Oh, wait.
I didn't want to go.
Damn it.
I didn't want to go to the entrance.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
But like clownfish are technically exotic fish.
So people didn't know how to take care of them very well.
Oh, wait.
We didn't go to front.
Wait, there's Critter County.
Oh.
Oh my god, I barely explored.
Oh my god, there's Winnie the Pooh!
Oh my god, there's Splash Mountain!
Or there's a new...
Oh my god, there's Teon.
Who the fuck are these two?
Oh, are these from the palace?
Oh, I want to go to the haunted mansion.
Who are...
Are these from the...
Palace of the Caribbean, right?
Like, who are these two?
Why would I want their photo?
Who's in Adventureland?
There's Aladdin.
What's in Frontier, lad?
I like how it's just Woody.
I'm like, wait, why is it just Woody?
Is he, oh, there's Jesse too, I guess.
I was like, why is it just like, he gets like the fucking
worst shit.
Oh, there's no take it.
They just put Woody there and only Woody.
Poor Woody.
Doesn't even get Jesse at all.
It's just Woody.
a mad hatter okay i want to wait there's like different
parts of fantasy lad he's all you need oh friend oh no no no
i want to i want to go to the haunted mansion
wait the stretching room
oh yeah she had a gift for me she's they've been begging me
to go to cinderella for like There are just chambers.
And strange and frightening sounds echo through the halls.
Whenever candle lights flicker.
Where the air is deathly still, that is the time when ghosts
are present.
Practicing their terror with ghoulish delight.
Go, go, go, go, go!
No!
The ghost!
Not the ghost!
My grim incantation.
How dare you enter with no invitation.
The haunted mansion from Eddie Murphy.
So you thought you could stop in- Was the movie that bad?
I don't remember it being that bad.
Here you have trespassed.
And here you will stay.
them be cast by each hideous shape to regions beyond with no
hope of escape i thought the movie was pretty all right i
was also a kid when i watched it freely you fall you tumble
and spin scream so the spirits will know you yeah i thought
it was all right the people were like i apparently was
really bad what happened oh don't don't I am your host.
Your ghost host.
There's no turning back now.
Our tour begins here in this gallery where you see paintings
of some of our guests as they appeared in their corruptible
I watched a video of some guy like stayed overnight at the
haunted mansion where everything was like turned off and
stuff.
It was so freaky.
It looked so scary.
because like everything was like turned off and like um even
like the waiting like the the line queue actually looks
really freaky like they got like exclusive disney permission
to like camp out at the haunted mansion
while like when everyone was like like what's when
everything was closed yeah wait i'm falling forward what the
fuck am i falling down
where's the hat box guy and hot and cold running chills
listen bash oh
Oh, it's like...
Hole in the wall.
I'm playing hole in the wall.
For a thousand.
Any volunteers?
You could try to mirror the face of the clock.
Time flies when you're having fun.
Yay.
Oh, I did not see him.
I did not see that guy.
What the fuck?
The fucking statue.
You almost look as though you've seen a ghost.
Look at the good ghost.
Shit.
I'm okay.
Just a little concussion wouldn't hurt anyone.
Look at the NFL players.
They're okay, right?
They seem okay.
Oh my god.
Do you dare to take what is not yours?
Hmm?
Yay!
All our ghosts have been dying to meet you.
This one can hardly contain himself.
You waved at me.
Alright, I'll grab this.
Are you having trouble getting food?
No, I'm okay.
Traversing this endless portal could take you forever.
Oh, wait, I thought he was like a nice portal.
You might find your way.
Yeah, I found my way eventually.
I did it.
Okay, it was a glowing blue portal.
I assume what portal taught me is that when it glows blue, I
should go through it.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that it was an evil
portal?
Huh?
How was I supposed to know that?
Oh my god, that's a huge last line for the haunted mansion.
Wait, where is this?
Where's the pirate?
No, we don't need to be another There's black party you
think you'll sign your book what the fuck is black up birdie
It's like there he is him?
Who is this guy like oh my god the most famous Disney star
Black party who are you?
It's a pleasure to meet you last black party the fears they
call me but I'll not be any trouble to eat I guess I'll I
guess I'll give you a hug Like who the most the most famous
character of them are
Johnny Depp was busy so they make black party Bro the dog
from the fucking past the Caribbean rat is more famous than
this guy As I'm truly famous I'm like oh he's a hero a kind
of hero are you bro he doesn't even hug he's like personal
space please here's to favorable fortune my favorite pilots
of the caribbean character yeah but the dog is more popular
than him i've seen the pilots the caribbean rat is here
hello hello there's me oh is that the tarzan thing before
they have to remove the tarzan right right the this was
before the tarzan The owners of the Tarzan people took over,
like, removed it.
They had to renovate the Tarzan ride because, like, they
lost the rights to it.
That's why, like, we don't have it no more.
Hey, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Just want to say I'm glad I found someone who's into the
Leon Stitch Show.
It was so cool when I was a kid.
I love all the little cousins.
Ruben was my favorite.
I fucking loved Ruben.
Ruben was so fucking funny.
Oh my god, I know, I know Cinderella.
I watched all the Lilo and Stitch episodes.
And also I have all the sequel movies.
The one, was it Lilo and Stitch?
Lilo and Stitch, the first movie before, you know, like it
was a movie.
Oh my god, it's Baloo!
Hello Baloo!
Oh, there's the Jungle Cruise!
Okay, I want to do the pilots of Caribbean Red.
The first Lilo and Stitch movie was The Cousins.
Oh yeah, Lilo and Stitch too.
with the electric cousin and then and then the show and then
was Leroy and Stitch Leroy and Stitch after and then I try
to watch the Japanese anime but I didn't fuck with it
because there wasn't there was no Lilo I know like the other
character was supposed to be like Lilo but Japanese but like
I can't you can't watch Lilo and Stitch without Lilo yeah
Stitch gets a glitch oh yeah yeah and Stitch.
I forgot about Stitch gets the glitch.
I have the DVDs of it too.
Yeah, and then I hated that, I hated that, like, they were
like, oh, it's because Lilo abandoned, like, they did a
cop-out for the anime, but they're like, the reason why
Lilo's not here is because Lilo abandoned Stitch for
college.
I'm like, why can't she bring Stitch to college?
I don't understand.
I was like, can't, why can she bring, bring him to college?
Yeah, like why did Lino abandon him?
I didn't understand that plot point.
I know, like this Ohana, bro, oh that's what happened in the
live action movie, too.
That's what happened.
Like, Nami in the live, live action, that was the problem in
the live action movie, because um, um, oh my god, it's
Fortune Red.
Okay, the problem was that um in the live action nami was
like i need a i will not bet i will not i need abandon you
for college the whole issue like the whole thing was that uh
i cannot like child protective services were trying to take
lilo away or some shit because like you know um they're like
oh you're not fit to take care of lilo and she's like no i
am and then in the end she like gave up lilo to like her
neighbor it was like i gotta go to college now
Like, I gotta go to college.
Like, go live with your neighbor.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
What does O'Hanna mean?
No, I don't want to...
I want to find the Pirates of the Caribbean ride.
I'm trying to find that right now.
Yeah, that was fucking crazy.
The way they handled that.
Oh, yeah, they got rid of Gantu, too.
I guess like CGI expensive like that's why like you know how
like in the original they had like Pliquly and um um oh my
god fuck who was the other guy Jumba Pliquly and Jumba sorry
I forgot I can't believe I almost forgot Jumba but you know
Pliquly was the star but they made Pliquia and Jumba put on
like human like uh human illusions or whatever Instead of
having them, like, put on, like, cost, like, put on, like, a
red, like, a t-shirt and pants and be like, I'm a human.
Because they didn't want to do CGI.
The CGI was too expensive.
Where the fuck is the Pirates of the Caribbean, right?
I don't want to visit the Pirates.
That's it.
I'm fast traveling.
Wait, where's the fast travel?
Yeah, the CGI budget ran out.
is it new orleans yeah where the fuck was this ride no you
know the crazy part you guys might be like how how they're
still making like leo and stitch the live action movie is no
currently number four or five for number four or five the
most uh the most earned animated film of 2025.
yeah there was like a top 10 of how many like what which
films made the most money which anime films made the most
money this year and lila and stitch was really like rank
four or five it did really well for how dumb the movie was
apparently well that was a fortuitous landing yeah it made
over a billion dollars oh my god it's that guy it's black
body for a bit of privateering and maritime entrepreneurial
already good fortune you see you happened it was under the
bridge and i happened to have me a treasure a pleasure man
have we gotten a card you row me to my destination and i'll
grant you a fair share of the treasure what do you say i
feel like boycotting is like it's really hard to have make
it work
cracked.
This is not my pies at the Caribbean?
Why the fuck am I rowing a boat?
Where are my pirates?
We're playing Double the blooms and neopets right now.
This is literally the the bloom game and neopets right now,
but what if it's 3D?
I'm fucking playing that stupid the bloom game for neopards.
They're not even singing the song!
Look short, mate.
Incoming Gator!
Gator!
Where's my pirate song?
That's it.
Give me out of here.
They didn't say- I was here Yo-ho!
Yo-ho!
A pirate's life for me.
If I can't have it, I'll sing it myself.
Oh, fuck this.
Did they play the song here?
Yo-ho, yo-ho, a pirate's life for me.
Oh my god, I get the fucking intro song on For the for the
fucking ride opening but not the actual stuff I saw him.
Yo ho, yo ho, a pirate's life for me.
Yeah, that's where it came from.
That's where Pirates of the Caribbean and the movie came
from.
They just took, like, inspiration to it.
Mickey Mouse rules.
Where am I?
Woody!
You got a friend in me.
Whoa.
I won't be surprised if.
I won't be surprised if this is his brother that's voicing
him.
There's no way Tom Hanks are.
Alright.
Tom Hanks, brother, take a photo of me.
Are you fucking?
Oh my god.
Okay, sorry.
Apparently I didn't indulge in capitalism enough.
So I guess we'll just say hi.
It's probably his brother.
Hey, partner.
Have you met the rest of the...
the roundup gang yet oh prospector pete is probably up in
the hill somewhere and my guess is jesse saddled up over by
yeah i'm pretty sure that's jim hey jim if you're heading
that way maybe you could deliver this no tour for me all
right let's do it yeah woody's coming apparently cast
members used to do that where they will just fall to the
ground when yeah docy do when you say But then there were
too many people kept abusing that and there were so many
injuries that they had to stop It would they don't do that
no more Thanks for asking that's mighty nice of you
For my favorite deputy.
That's me I'm his favorite not you guys.
It's me or Annie's coming.
Yeah, Annie's coming.
I'm here for it That's mighty sweet of you and they don't do
that no more they they're scared of like lawsuits now
yeah well so long partner don't forget to drop by big
thunder ranch with that note no need to be shy guys a good
guy would not have to would not say that he's one of the
good guys wait where's my trickster who's that which one did
i get from that oh a stitch my his handwriting is pretty
nice for an alien Sorry!
Martian.
That's his name.
Yay.
There he is.
Woody.
Okay, let's party.
What the fuck?
Where is it?
Okay, let's party.
Black body.
Yeah, an alien has better handwriting than me.
All right, let's do it.
Let's get one more arc.
Oh my god, it's already almost three hours.
Oh, it's just like.
like Disneyland that's barely nothing in Disneyland I'm fast
traveling I'm getting lost in this map who do I want to last
autograph I don't know whose autograph I want I got all the
Ming oh the shipping down I want shipping down give me the
tune down I love shipping down
I had Chippendale phase.
I had a Donald phase and a Chippendale phase.
Where is he?
Chippendale!
Get up!
Move out of the way!
Move out!
That's Pluto.
Where the fuck is Chippendale?
You look like you're having fun.
Where are they?
They have their own show and movie!
Where's my John Malady and...
standing.
I'm chipping down!
What the fuck?
Why are you so fucking big?
Oh my god.
Someone fucking roided up our rodents.
Hello!
I am afraid.
I'm bailed.
Nice to meet you.
Oh my god.
Yay!
Why are they so big?
All right,
can you sign my autograph?
Yay!
And so!
Rescue Rangers!
Where's Gadget?
Can I also have Gadget's autograph too?
Aww, that's cute.
Aww.
I like that.
Guys, can I also meet Gadget?
Like...
Did you know Gadget has a Russian cult?
That worships her?
Fun fact.
What?
Yeah, there's a Russian cult that worships Gadget.
I mean, like, look at her.
Who wouldn't want to start a cult over her?
Like, yeah, who could blame them?
No, it is real.
It is real.
Let me look.
Let me pull it up.
Russian cult gadget.
There is a Russian cult religion that worships gadget hack
wrench from Chippendale Rescue Ring.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll show you as a picture.
That's actually crazy.
This picture does not look real, but apparently it is.
Yeah.
Why the fuck?
I mean, who can really blame them?
Yeah, let me read a quote.
She is the divine being, the most untouched and perfect
sibling of the great God on earth.
Why I love her?
It's a super question.
How I can't love the goddess.
She is strict, cute, optimistic, and her level of technical
knowledge is unachievable for a mortal being.
Those are just a few of the testimonies.
Wait, let's look at these guys.
Wait, look at this photo.
They're just...
Forget it.
I like how they're just like Wait, what the fuck?
They have like a fucking Step dinner with our Lord and
Savior Gadget Where should I Sign up?
You gotta be in Russia Yeah, it's a Russian exclusive,
unfortunately Wait, there's this And then, wait, this one,
this picture is pretty Funny Look at this one Look at this
one Would I not save this one?
Did it save?
Why is it not saving?
This is such an important picture that I must show you guys.
Oh my god, it's crazy.
Chrome refuses to save this very important picture.
Okay, I have to...
Oh my god, it keeps denying me the save for the save this
insecure download block.
Oh, I think this one is funny.
Wait, let me save this.
Here you go.
If I get a virus for downloading some random Russian cults
website, then It was worth it.
It was absolute.
I will say it was absolutely worth it.
This is how I like to get my Russian malware.
I think this one was good too.
And I should stop saving the images themselves.
I'm just going to crop it.
I mean, it's too late.
I already saved it onto my PC.
It's too late.
I got the Russian malware.
here this one this one is crazy the gadget try this looks
like a great oh wait this one this is like the last meal
this is like the last meal in on in the bible but with
gadget instead
this is that's jesus and they're having the last last supper
yet the last supper
I'm talking about the Russian cult that celebrates that
worships Gadget from Chippendale the Gadget's last supper
where can we join someone's like we got we sold them
Look at the guy.
This is silly.
The future of our great nation.
It is bleak.
Education is declining.
Young people are turning into crazy freaks.
It seems the citizens are not happy.
We gave away the motherland.
We sold ourselves to the west.
Oh my god, the fucking comments are wild.
and then someone below the rescue rangers was pretty cool
oh apparently gadget is like extremely popular in russia
like to russian men is actually it's not even like a joke
people some this like this russian commenter was like random
russia here i legitimately thought that gadget was very
popular it was a cultural icon around the world because she
is very popular uh towards russian men among russian men
but why russian specifically because they have taste
i like how the one of them was like i can't believe them
they sold themselves to the west Gadget is Russia's ocean.
Oh, it's the picture still on the screen.
This is a very important, let me, this is very important.
Let me put it here.
I'll put it in the court.
I want one more autograph before we call it here.
Oh, I barely fucking, I realized like, I barely made any
progress in this game.
This game has so much shit in it.
That's crazy.
not realize three hours have almost passed.
I've been like, I felt like I was Ashley and Disneyland.
Belle!
Oh my god!
Emma Watson!
Bonjour, mademoiselle.
Bonjour!
My name's Belle.
It's so nice to meet you.
I'll never get Cinderella's present.
I found Belle first.
Enchante.
Wait, yeah, the live action is played by emma watson it's
crazy like if you were in a book you know like because emma
watson is all about singing but i'm sorry not emma watson
bell was all about singing but they literally like emma
watson does not sing which is such a crazy casting choice if
you ever if you listen to like the songs she sang for the
movie it was like super fucking autotune it's so bad Yeah,
they auto-tuned her like crazy When you look inside your
book I hope you'll think of me Yeah And I'll get a hug Yeah,
they auto-tuned her really really hard Which is crazy to say
because there's like mixing You can get mixers where like it
doesn't sound Really auto-tuned Like even if she can't hit
the exact notes But like I don't know Like I guess Disney
cheaped out Like the movie so who cares because like like
there's mixing there's like like disney can like fucking
hire the most expensive mixers to make it so that doesn't
sound like it's auto-tuned but yet like i don't know they
maybe they're just they're just thinking like whatever you
guys are still gonna pay money anyway like i know you'll
still pay for it oh yeah oh i want to grab it i got Off with
her head.
Why it's a little girl?
I am her majesty, the queen.
And they're just like, why pay for an expensive mixer?
You'll still buy the tickets anyway.
It's Emma Watson.
Alright.
She will be my last autograph.
We'll never get the gift from Cinderella.
Oh.
AKZ, thank you for the five gifted ships.
They get the ender right.
Yeah, they were.
I'm pretty sure they made a lot of money still.
People are like, why do they still make live action?
Because they still make money.
Oh my god, it's upside down.
It's because there's Wonderland.
And it's much better than it was.
They make money.
Even though we think they don't, they do.
I'm always surprised how much money they make from live
action films.
We think they don't, but they do.
There's a world that exists out there.
side of Twitter that was so that was still believe of that
are still like suckling on Disney's live action teet.
I know it's always the teacups.
Teacups are always fun.
Wait, I want to go to the bat.
Okay, wait, I gotta get the mad hatters autograph.
I swear I do.
I'm a real boy.
I like waving.
Oh, your nose is growing.
You not like waving?
Freak.
Where is the...
Wait, where's the Manhattan?
Where is he?
They said, oh, there he is.
I'm very happy on birthday to you, to me, to you, to me.
I'm very happy on birthday to you.
Yes, you!
Yes, me!
I love that song.
How do you do, my dear?
Uh-huh.
Yeah!
My birthday to you, to me, to you, to me!
Happy birthday to you, to me!
Alright, can you sign my thingy?
Yay!
Back then, on DeviantArt, everybody would, like, be she-fied
Mad Hatter and make him, like, a handsome boy.
A handsome man.
And then you all remembers the good old days on the
internet.
He made him a hot man in fan art.
He was the original one.
He was!
I wish I was joking because like, um, for the, especially at
Disneyland, um, especially for Disneyland, uh, they would
have like, like, a really tall man.
Cost, not cost, but, um, as the cast member.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
Still waiting for me.
All right, let me see if I can find it right real quick.
Uh, the mad hatter.
And people would like freak out about fighting.
him at disneyland too mad hatter disneyland cat uh
disneyland
because now they get old men to do it now but back then they
would get like young guys to to uh be the mad hatter no i'm
literally just googling it
Now they just cast older men now.
But before then, it was like young guys.
And then there was like fan art of it everywhere.
Where's my...
He was like the OG once there.
And people would freak out at Disneyland when they see Mad
Hatter.
And then there was...
Wait.
He got like so much fan art too on Tumblr and DeviantArt.
Mad Hatter.
oh my god yeah because it was like okay it was like the
classic disney princesses oh my god okay i'm gonna show you
guys a fan art that was like a classic that everyone Let's
see it.
Let's see if I can find it.
Disney Princesses fan art.
Oh my god, where was it?
Okay, I'm sorry, Mad Hatter.
Let me move.
Let me move here.
Because it's from this artist, and she would draw it.
This one.
Some people might remember this fan art.
Because she was like...
She was like the ringleader.
And the Mad Hatter.
fan of this artwork.
Does anyone remember this?
This was a classic artwork on DeviantArt.
Like everyone like it was so famous.
Like the Simpson one too.
Like the Simpsons anime artwork.
So this artist was like the ring leader for like the Mad
Hatter obsession.
And she would like she would like literally draw Mad Hatter
like almost every fucking day.
and wait let me i don't remember her her uh the artist like
who the artist was but like she was so famous because she
would always just draw mad hatter and mad hatter you said i
could find her art and all right
and she was very mad she was really mad about the Johnny
Depp version of Mad Hatter because she was like duh my oh
shit why did they make them like ugly now and she was so mad
and I remember she like posted like rants about it on her
even our journal about how fucking obsessed she was upset
she was that they made the Mad Hatter ugly
But he was like, he was basically the OG Wensler Before the
Wensler came out
But yeah, God You know what, fine, we will find Cinderella
But um Where does Cinderella?
Cinderella should be close to her castle, right?
I know I kept saying last one But you know what, I'll get
last one for real Because everyone keeps yelling at me to
get Cinderella's gift where
is he where is Cinderella you would assume she's near
Cinderella's castle right but that's no way and then there's
Mickey I don't fuck a Cinderella Cinderella Cinderella okay
there's awesome oh no that's Aurora I was like it's in there
oh Aurora sorry but miss you know typical mistake you know
Everyone makes that mistake confusing Aurora for Cinderella.
There she is!
Cinderella!
Hello!
Yeah, it's Cinderella's castle.
Is it not?
Or is it Sleeping Beauty's castle?
Oh no.
I have a surprise for you.
It's a magic wand from my fairy god.
Oh!
you do many wonderful things take care of this special gift
and remember use it wisely it's almost time to go to the
ball the ball dress for such a royal occasion why is this
not good find me some fabric and a needle and thread i do i
not look beautiful special to wear with the help of my
friends the mice it'll take no time at all not beautiful
cinderella your eyes, my fish eyes, and tell me I'm
beautiful.
Yay.
I thought I was beautiful.
My parents allowed me.
Yay!
You'd like me to sign this?
Oh, yes, please.
I had to go after my book, please.
And then I was going to sell it on YouTube.
bay make sure it's a blue pen so i can transfer it
that's crazy i'm never signing autographs with a blue pen
anymore after i found that out it's blue yeah blue markers
apparently like apparently if people uh if you get given a
blue marker um it's mostly because like they want to like
make replicas of your autograph yeah I think it's the color.
It's either color blue or red.
So, like, people are like...
So, like, celebrities are like...
That's why celebrities refuse to sign autographs with, like,
colored markers.
Because you can literally...
You can, like, forge signatures with blue markers.
It's because you can transfer it or some shit.
Oh, shit.
I get...
I would never autograph something with a blue marker.
Yeah, it's easier to come.
Happy.
What does the magic wand do?
Can I do that?
Something sparkly that catches your eye.
Just move it!
Biffity bopity boom!
Woo!
Zep-fity boop!
Zep!
ZAP!
That fucking caused a chaos.
Emergency!
There's a child with a magic wand!
ZAP!
They have to close Disneyland down because the child got
another wand.
ZAP.
Zap
We're gonna call it here.
We're not giving you a oh, does it where?
Oh, I got sewing materials since when I'm just zapping.
I am not Like out of that zap zap zap zap
We got the sewing material.
Wait, okay, wait If I want to see what Cinderella makes me.
Cinderella, Cinderella.
Uh, she does.
Thank you.
The super chat.
I've seen skin scenes.
I look like the ones.
I was wanting whom.
Oh, it's from, uh, Gurria.
Gurria?
Gurria.
Buga Studios.
I have a credit to my 900k celebration.
But her name is Gurria.
Oh, and if you happen to find you a super chat.
Thank you.
sure we can put it to good use i'm not even looking at her
she's like talking to me and i was like i just want to zap
we'll need quite a lot for all the things we planned any
thread i thought you're going to make me clothes what
where's my clothes that you're gonna wear that you're gonna
make me zap zap zap zap all right i'm gonna call it here or
keep zapping i have to i have to call it This game was a lot
more, um, a lot, what's the word?
A lot more intense, not intensive, bigger than I thought.
I just want to snap.
Vast, yeah.
Yeah, it was a lot, a lot more vast than I thought it was.
A lot more elaborate.
It was fun, no.
enjoyed going to disneyland with me guys yeah i do have
another stream today in like an hour and a half like not
even a half an hour and 20 minutes so i had to call it here
there was a lot more content than i expected from from a an
old connect game um but i hope you guys had fun hanging out
with me um being immersed in disneyland with me and meeting
all our favorite characters and our favorite Disney rides.
I had a fun time with everyone.
I do have a sponsored stream later tonight, so please check
it out.
It does help out future streams alive.
You guys stop by or click on the link for my sponsored
stream.
It is Nikkei.
I know that's why I, that's the only reason why I scheduled
this Disneyland stream today and not tomorrow because I just
thought it would be funny and like, oh, in the morning she
plays Disneyland and in the night She gets freaky with the
half-naked women.
The whiplash.
Dokey at night versus like, what was it called?
After dark.
Dokey after dark.
The Disney after party.
After dark hours.
I do too cute.
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys have a fun night.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Or check out the sponsor's stream tonight.
Anyway, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry, I had like a little brain fart right there.
it's like where was that but let me do that as always
everybody say hi jade pause i had too much fun zapping guys
as always everybody say hi jade pause check get up and move
around get that blood flowing if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye